THE ASSEMBLY IS NOW IN SESSION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
ACOSTA.
AGUIAR-CURRY.
ALLEN ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BERMAN.
BIGELOW. BLOOM.
BONTA. BROUGH.
BURKE CABALLERO.
CALDERON CARILLO CERVANTES
CHAU. CHAVEZ
CHEN. DAVID CHIU CHOI. KANSEN
CHU. COOLEY
COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM. DALLY.
DALY. EGGMAN FLORA.
FONG.
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN.
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA. GIPSON GLORIA
GONZALEZ FLETCHER. GRAY. GRAYSON
HARPER HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER.
KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KILEY LACKEY LEVINE LIMON ALONE.
LOW. MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES
MCCARTY. MEDINA MELENDEZ
MULLIN MURATSUCHI. NAZARIAN
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL PATTERSON
QUIRK QUIRK SILVA. REYES
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO.
SALAS SANTIAGO.
STEINORTH STONE.
THURMOND
TING VOEPEL WALDRON. WEBER WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND
IN THE GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND
FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER.
WILL BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN THE REVEREND BOB OSHITA.
REVEREND OSHITA.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
FOR DECADES.
I'VE GIVEN BITS OF ADVICE TO OUR
COLLEGE BOUND HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS.
MANY HAVE COME TO AFFECTIONATELY
CALLED HIM REVEREND BOB SCHOOLS.
ONE OF THE RULES IS THIS.
NEVER SAY I LOVE YOU
ROMANTICALLY UNTIL YOU'RE TWENTY
SIX.
JUST THIS PAST SPRING ONE
COLLEGE YOUNG COLLEGE FRESHMEN
CALLED ME FROM SCHOOL.
HER FIRST RELATIONSHIP OF
COMMITMENT HAD ENDED AND SHE WAS
HEARTBROKEN.
TO STILL FRESH TEARS HE SAID TO
ME. YOU'RE RIGHT REVEREND BOB.
I SHOULD HAVE LISTENED TO YOU I
JUST DIDN'T REALLY UNDERSTAND.
SHE COULD TELL I WAS SMILING
WHEN I SAID TO HER. MY RULES
WERE MADE TO BE BROKEN.
I EXPLAIN IT ONLY HURTS BECAUSE
YOU REALLY CARED.
AND WHAT I HAD SHARED WITH YOU
WAS JUST KNOWLEDGE.
WHAT YOU FEEL NOW AND KNOWING
NOW?
THAT IS WITH THEM.
WE STILL CHECKING WE THE TETHER
AND SHE IS ON THE MEND AND DOING
WELL.
BUT AT HER YOUNG AGE SHE KNOWS
WELL THAT REAL WISDOM IS
EXPERIENTIAL.
IN TIME. WITH WISDOM EYES OPEN I
AM CONFIDENT YOU WILL FIND
YOURSELF IN A RELATIONSHIP
WORTHY OF HER LOVE AND TRUST.
WHEN OUR KNOWLEDGE IS NURTURED
BY OUR LIFE EXPERIENCES
WISDOM TAKES ROOT.
AND DEEPENS OUR UNDERSTANDING.
OUR APPRECIATION AND OUR EMPATHY.
NOW MORE MEDIA.
THE KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE
BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WALDRON AS HE LEADS US IN
THE PLEDGE MISS WALDRON.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN SALUTING THE
FLAG.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE.
NATION.
IT IS.
RADIATION.
THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO THURSDAY MAY TWENTY
FOURTH TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE
TELEMEDICINE AND I AM ON A ROCKY
DAY CHAVEZ ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SEVENTIES THAT DISTRICT
PRESIDING CHEAPER SUGAR CALDERON
MOVES AND MISS WALDRON SECONDS
THAT THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
AND MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE
THERE ARE NONE.
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES
FOR THE DAY.
FOR LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
NAY MON.
MCCARTY.
AND MEDINA.
FOR PERSONAL BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
QUIRK.
CUNNINGHAM AND STEINORTH.
FOR A FUNERAL THE DEATH IN THE
FAMILY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MELISSA
MELENDEZ.
MOVING TO PROCEDURAL MOTIONS
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTION
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON.
I SPEAK ON ADJOURNMENT A MEMORY
TODAY WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER PURSUANT TO
ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SIX I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE
REFER TO THE FOLLOWING BILLS TO
COMMITTEE. AS BEFORE ANYONE PAN
FROM THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE TO
THE RULES COMMITTEE S. B. SIX
NINETY NINE GALGIANI FOR THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE SJR TWENTY FOUR
JACKSON. FROM THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE TO THE PURSE COMMITTEE
AND SB SEVEN TWENTY ALLEN FROM
EDUCATION COMMITTEE TO THE
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE AND
THEN BACK TO THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION AGAINST SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE ON
RECONSIDERATION ITEMS FOR FIVE.
SIX AND SEVEN.
WILL BE CONTINUE.
WE ARE ON TO THE THIRD READING
FILE THIS IS.
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT ACR TO
FORTY ONE BY MISTER RODRIGUEZ
MEMBERS.
PLEASE GIVE YOUR ATTENTION TO
MISTER RODRIGUEZ THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TO FORTY ONE BY SELLING NUMBER
RODRIGUEZ RELATIVE TO
CARDIOPULMONARY RESTS
RESUSCITATION.
MISS RODRIGUEZ.
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS ACR
TO FORTY ONE RECOGNIZES JUNE
FIRST THROUGH JUNE SEVENTH ASK
CARDIOPULMONARY RESUSCITATION AN
AUTOMATED EXTERNAL DEFIBRILLATOR
AWARENESS WEEK.
HEART DISEASE IS THE LEADING
CAUSE OF DEATH IN CALIFORNIA AND
IT AFFECTS MEN WOMEN AND
CHILDREN OF ALL BACKGROUNDS.
CARDIAC ARREST CAN OCCUR AT ANY
TIME OR PLACE.
OFTEN IT IS A BYSTANDER WHO
ADMINISTER CPR AND BY THE
TRAINING. DOESN'T AS MANY AS
PEOPLE AS POSSIBLE WE ARE
DOUBLING THE CHANCES OF SURVIVAL.
HAVING PROPER TRAINING AND
IMPLEMENTATION PLANS CAN MAKE
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN LIFE AND
DEATH.
MEMBERS FEEL FREE TO JOIN ME
TODAY AT TEN AM FOR SIDEWALK CPR.
WITH THE AMERICAN HEART
ASSOCIATION LOCATED IN THE NORTH
STEPS OF THE CAPITOL. RESPECT ME
OUT FOR AYE VOTE AND WOULD LIKE
TO REQUEST THAT THE ROLE FIRST
WILL BE OPEN FOR COAUTHORS.
THANK YOU MISTER RODRIGUEZ.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION. ON THE
RESOLUTION BEFORE THE BODY.
IT'S RODRIGUEZ HE WOULD LIKE CO
AUTHORS ON THE FIRST ROW YES.
THE AUTHORS YOUR QUESTION THAT
THE FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. AMBITIOUS IS
CO AUTHORS THIS IS CO AUTHORS AC
ARE TO FORTY ONE.
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
THE CLERK.
WELL CLOSER ALL THERE ARE SIXTY
ONE CO AUTHORS ADDED THEM
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE. ON THIS RESOLUTION
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
I ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
PASS RETAIN ON FILE ITEM NUMBER
NINE.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN ACR
TO FORTY SIX BY. MISTER CALDERON.
THE CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION TO FORTY
SIX BY SOME THE MEMBER CALLED
AROUND RELATIVE TO WORLD OCEANS
DAY.
MEMBERS.
PLEASE GIVE RETENTION MAJORITY
LEADER.
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
AND MEMBERS ACR TO FORTY SIX.
I IS ABOUT WORLD OCEANS DAY AND
RECOGNIZING THAT.
JUNE EIGHTH OF THIS YEAR IS
WORLD OCEANS DAY.
.
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE TO ME FOR A LOT OF OBVIOUS
REASONS BECAUSE OF MY BACKGROUND
GROWING UP SURFING SPENDING.
VIRTUALLY EVERY DAY IN THE
OCEANS AND SALAS.
SEVEN YEARS OLD.
.
YOU KNOW I I'VE HAD EXPERIENCES
IN THE OCEAN THAT HAVE MEANT SO
MUCH TO ME. ARE AND THAT HAVE
BEEN SUCH AN INTEGRAL PART OF MY
LIFE.
.
NOT WHEN YOU WHEN YOU'RE SURFING
IN AND INNER SENDING UP ON A
WAVING YOU LITERALLY HAVE A
DOLPHIN RIGHT HERE. AT YOUR FEET
THAT YOU CAN REACH DOWN AND JUST
TOUCH WELTS ON THE SAME WAY AS
AN EXPERIENCE UNLIKE ANYTHING
ELSE.
YOU COULD EXPERIENCE IN YOUR
LIFE.
BUT THERE ARE OTHER THINGS.
THAT.
YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN ABLE TO
EXPERIENCE THAT ARE APART FROM
SURFING ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
WAS ABLE TO DO WHEN I WAS
YOUNGER. AS MY MOTHER.
SHE WOULD TAKE US OUT WHALE
WATCHING ME PLAY HOOKY FROM
SCHOOL. AND WE GO WHALE WATCHING
EARLY IN THE MORNING.
AND THE HOUSE ME IN MIGHT MIGHT
TWO OF MY BROTHERS AND ME AND
STEVE AND I WAS LIKE SOME OF THE
BEST EXPERIENCE.
EXPERIENCES OF MY LIFE BECAUSE
THERE'S JUST SOMETHING THE THREE
OF US GET TOGETHER YOU KNOW SO
COOL TO SEE ALL THE JELLY FISH.
YOU NOD YOUR DRY GOING OUT TO
SEAL THE DOLPHINS AND WHEN YOU
SEE A WHALE IT'S LIKE THE BEST
EXPERIENCE EVER.
AND THERE ARE MANY EXPERIENCES
FROM MILLIONS OF PEOPLE LIKE
THIS ALL OVER THE STATE. ALL
OVER THE WORLD IN A LOT OF
PEOPLE SITTING RIGHT HERE ON
THIS FLOOR HAVE THEIR OWN
SIMILAR EXPERIENCES. WHEN IT
COMES TO THE OCEAN AYE BUT THE
REASON WHY I'M DEALING AYE I'M
DOING THIS RESOLUTION IS BECAUSE
WE HAVE A PROBLEM IN OUR OCEANS
ARE DYING.
WE HAVE.
COUPLE WHALES THAT HAVE BEEN
WASHING UP ON BEACHES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND AROUND THE WORLD
THAT WE HAD A WHALE WASHED UP ON
THE BEACH IN THAILAND WITH. OVER
EIGHTY PLASTIC BAGS IN ITS
STOMACH.
TWENTY POUNDS OF PLASTIC IN ITS
STOMACH
WHICH BECAUSE IT'S DEATH WE HAD
WHALE HERE IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WHAT'S UPON THE BEACH.
WITH THIRTY POUNDS OF PLASTIC.
IN ITS STOMACH.
WE HAVE.
US THE WHOLE Y. OF THE STATE OF
HAWAI JUST PASSED ACTUALLY A LAW
BANNING A LOT OF THE SUN SCREENS
THAT WE USE EVERY DAY. AND THE
REASON WHY IS BECAUSE IT WAS
FOUND THAT CERTAIN INGREDIENTS
WITHIN THE SUNSCREENS ARE
ACTUALLY CONTRIBUTING TO THE
DEATH.
CORAL REEFS REEFS ARE IN HAWAI.
I. WHICH IS A HUGE PART OF THE
ECOSYSTEM OF THE OCEAN.
AND AND SO WE ARE HAVING ALL
THESE MAJOR IMPACTS ON THE OCEAN
AND. YOU KNOW IT'S KIND OF
PASSING AS BLIND WE'RE NOT TAKEN
A MOMENT TO TO THINK ABOUT THE
IMPACT THAT WE'RE HAVING. WE ALL
LOVE OUR CONVENIENCE AS WE ALL
LOVE OF BEING ABLE TO YOU KNOW
USE A PLASTIC STRAW ARE A
PLASTIC CUP AND IT'S FINE IF WE
WANT TO USE IT BUT WE HAVE TO BE.
RESPONSIBLE WITH HOW WE DISCARD
WITH THAT.
WITH THOSE PRODUCTS AND BE MORE
COGNIZANT OF THE IMPACT THAT
WERE HAVING ON THE OCEAN BECAUSE.
THE MAJORITY OF THE WORLD GETS
ITS FOOD FROM THE OCEAN AND WHEN
THESE FISH ARE EATING CLASSIC
WE'RE EATING THE FISH AND WE'RE
IN THE PLASTIC AND WE'RE REALLY
NOT QUITE SURE ABOUT WHAT IMPACT
THAT'S HAVING. ON US AND SO I
WANTED TO.
DO THIS THIS RESOLUTION TO
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
WORLD OCEANS DAY I MEAN AND IT'S
NOT JUST THE HEALTH OF THE OCEAN
WE HAVE ECONOMIES. IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA LOCAL ECONOMIES
OUR STATE ECONOMY THEIR
ECONOMIES AROUND THE WORLD THAT
DEPEND ON THE HEALTH.
pIMPORTANT WE TAKE THE TIME TO
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
OCEAN NOT JUST OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BUT TO THE WORLD AND
THE IMPACT IT HAS ON OUR LIVES.
AND SO WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE AND ASK THAT
THE FIRST ROLL CALL BE OPEN FOR
CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MISTER CALDERON MISTER
LEVINE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I ALSO JOIN
MY COLLEAGUE IN SUPPORTING THIS
RESOLUTION.
WE'VE WE OF COURSE NEED TO BE OF
MUCH MORE CAREFUL ABOUT OUR
WASTE STREAM BUT EVERY DAY. THE
EMISSIONS THAT WE ARE RELEASE
SCENE WHEN WE ARE BURNING AYE
CARBON INTO THE ATMOSPHERE AYE
IS POISONING OUR OCEANS OUR
OCEANS ARE CERTIFYING AT A RATE
FASTER THAN THEY'VE A CERTIFIED.
IN THE PAST THREE HUNDRED
MILLION YEARS WHICH IS ACTUALLY
KILLING WILDLIFE IN THE OCEANS
AND AFFECTING OUR COASTAL
ECONOMIES AS WELL WE MUST TREAT
OUR OCEANS WITH MORE RESPECT
PLEASE VOTE FOR ACR TO FORTY SIX.
THANK YOU MISS LEVINE
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL COMMENT.
ON THE RESOLUTION MISTER
CALDERON PASS IN THE FIRST ROW
BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
ON THE RESOLUTION MEMBERS THIS
IS ACR TO FORTY SIX THE COURT
WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON AUTHORS
COAUTHORS.
ON THE RESOLUTION THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHOR MEMBERS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
THE CLERK WILL. CLOSER ALL THERE
ARE FIFTY SEVEN CO AUTHORS AT ON
THE RESOLUTION WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
THE SESSION SCHEDULE. IS AS
FOLLOWS.
FRIDAY JUNE EIGHTH.
NO FLOOR SESSION NO CHECK IN
SESSION MONDAY JUNE ELEVENTH.
FLOOR SESSION IS AT ONE PM.
IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION THE
QUORUM CALLS LIFTED AND WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
THE GERMANS IN MEMORY.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WHO WERE
IN A PRIOR PERMISSION TO SPEAK
ON ADJOURNMENT IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS I AM GOING TO ASK THAT
YOU PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS OR
REMOVE YOUR CONVERSATIONS FROM
THE FLOOR.
SO WE MAY GIVE OUR RESPECTFUL
ATTENTION TO MISTER GIBSON WHO
WILL BE ADJOURNING IN THE MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR REMOVE.
YOUR CONVERSATION.
FROM THE FLOOR
.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TOP OF THE GREEN CARPET
.
THANK YOU MEMBERS MEMBERS PLEASE
GIVE YOUR ATTENTION TO MISTER
GIPSON MISTER GIBSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS.
I WOULD LIKE TO ASK HIS BODY TO
ADJOURN THE MEMORY OF PAST THREE
MEREDITH A DAVID BUGS A PASTOR
BOOKS WAS BORN ON MARCH
FOURTEENTH. NINETEEN TWENTY FIVE
AND HOMER LOUISIANA WHERE HE
GREW UP HE ATTENDED SCHOOL UP TO
JUNIOR HIGH SCHOOL. BUT DID NOT
COMPLETE HIS HIGH SCHOOL
EDUCATION HE USED TO SAY WHAT I
LACK IN FORMAL EDUCATION GOD
MADE UP.
WE'RE UP UP WITH ME WITH WISDOM
AND DIRECTION.
PASTOR MEREDITH BOOK WAS
MARRIED TO HIS WIFE.
WHICH THEY HAVE.
FIVE CHILDREN.
STARTING A CHURCH.
IN CARSON CALLED CARSON
COMMUNITY PRAYER BIBLE BAND. OF
WHICH LATER MERGED WITH CENTRAL
BAPTIST CHURCH.
HE AND HIS WIFE OF FAITHFULLY
SERVED OF FOR FORTY FIVE YEARS.
IN THAT COMMUNITY PASSED THE
MERIT OF BUG. BUGS WAS THE ONLY
SPIRITUAL LEADER AT CENTRAL
BAPTIST CHURCH BECAUSE HE
STARTED THE THE CHURCH.
FROM THE FIRST DAY. I HE AUTHOR
HE OFFERED.
COMPUTER CLASSES OF FED THE
HOMELESS.
OPEN UP A FOOD BANK IN A FOOD
DISTRIBUTION AS WELL AS.
PROVIDE IT WEEKLY BRETT SEE
ANYONE THAT NEEDED IT. ON MAY
SIXTEENTH.
AFTER NINETY THREE YEARS.
GOD HAS BLESSED US WITH HIM OF
GOD CALLED PASTOR BOOKS OWN HOME
HE LEAVE BEHIND FIVE BEAUTIFUL
CHILDREN. ON TWENTY
GRANDCHILDREN SEVEN GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN AND A WHOLE HOST
OF FAMILY AND FRIENDS AND AS A
SIDE NOTE.
AT NIGHT THREE YEARS OLD HE WAS
ALWAYS CHALLENGING PEOPLE TO
PLAY DOMINOS A ONE OF MY REGRETS
IS THAT NOT BEING ABLE TO MAKE
THE TIMES ACTUALLY.
PLAYED DOMINOS OF PASTOR BOOKS
HE WAS A VERY QUIET MAN A VERY
POWERFUL MEN IN THE CARS
COMMUNITY WE WILL MISS HIM
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT
WE ADJOURN THIS.
MEETING IN MEMORY OF PASTOR
DAVID BOOKS.
THANK YOU MISTER GIBSON MEMBERS
PLEASE READ THE NAMES OF THE
DEATHS REPRINTED IN THE JOURNAL
ALL REQUESTS TO RETURN A MEMORY
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL OF ALL OTHER
ITEMS REMAINING WILL BE PASSED
TO RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MISTER GIBSON MOVES MR LOW
SECONDS.
AT THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL MONDAY JUNE ELEVENTH AT
ONE P. M. WE ARE ADJOURNED